hello i'm andrew lee and my project is a
cell type specific expression and
protein interaction analysis to identify
autonomous genes
there is a high problems of autism as
one in 44 children are afflicted by the
disorder
the clinical diagnosis has been limited
by the lack of conclusive biomarkers and
the high genetic and clinical
heterogeneity in regards to autism's
etiology and the hallmark symptoms
early diagnosis for autism is essential
as the cognitive therapy intervention
loses its effectiveness during an early
stage of adolescence and there are two
main biological reasons for this the
first is that neuronal plasticity
declines and secondly the opportunity
for complex neuron growth is lost
there are three cases for autism
diagnosis the first is when autumn is
confirmed which would then follow a
behavioral and developmental monitoring
approach
for negative autism cases there are a
variety of other tests to test for other
neurological conditions
however for autism speculation cases
this is dependent on genetic testing
through the screening of chromosomal and
genetic mutations
however the accuracy of genetic testing
is highly dependent on discovering new
autism-rich genes
the safari database classifies known
austen genes based on their strength of
association into gene categories as
syndromic high confidence strong
candidate and suggestive evidence with
gene scores of 1 2 and 3.
however there is a growing lack of
consensus as only about 100 high
confidence genes have been found at the
estimated 1000
many genes lack genome-wide association
significance they lack replication or
have an unclear functional correlation
to autism symptoms
prior approaches have tried to identify
syndromic genes using genome-wide
association and expression profiling
there have been two major advancements
and also in genetic understanding
firstly there is high autism expression
specificity as 88 of the known genes
have been found in the early
developmental tissue
autism genes also have high conservation
and disease-implicated pathways which
means that genes that confer risks for
autism are functionally related there
are three major biological processes
involved with these autism genes firstly
neurotransmitter transport seen figure
2a
synapse regulation scene for your 2b and
5 classes of autism dysregulatory
receptors seen for your 2c
my first purpose was to visualize single
cell rna-seq ultimate candidate gene
expression across 26 cell types and also
to test the accuracy of the approach and
separating known autism from the
non-associated genes
next i sought to identify novel
autonomous genes through expression
profiling
and lastly to identify biological
support for the k genes using kinase and
transcription factors for their past
known austin correlations and also to
correlate the genes back to the three
biological processes i had shown in
figure two
single cell rna-seq data of the human
midbrain was obtained and a training set
of 91 high confidence genes from the
safari database and a testing set of
likely gene disrupting variants
i then developed a cell type specific
gene expression analysis and confirmed
the accurate stratification of the
autism and non-associated genes through
two tests
the first was by calculating the average
expression of all
19532 genes and 26 cell types and
comparing them to the safari autumn high
confidence averages the second test was
to compare the hierarchical clustering
separation for autism genes of varying
association confidence levels
i then identify new potential risk genes
through a gene expression analysis
26 cell types out of over 30 from the
original data were chosen and these are
expressed in greater than 10 cells and
all the rna-seq cell types analyzed had
shrunk association with autism and these
are seen in table two for example
dopaminergic cells have been correlated
with abnormal axon morphology and
reduced dopamine binding
for the first test there were clear
differentiations between gene score 2
and gene score 3 gene expression
it was found that more strong kidney
genes with gene score 2 were
hierarchically clustered with the safari
high confidence genes compared to the
same set of high comic genes with the
suggestive evidence genes at gene score
3
and this means that increased autism
association is correlated with increased
expression similarity between the safari
high confidence genes and the testing
set
this also supports that expression
profile analysis can differentiate
between close levels of autism
association
for the second test i compared the cell
types to the expression between the
safari autumn genes and the 19 000 other
genes it was found that the safari high
confident genes had higher expression
levels two to three folds compared to
the average of all genes especially in
the dopaminergic and the gaba neurons
this supports the extra from profiling
can differentiate between awesome and
non-associated gene sets
differentiate clustering was also found
with the safari genes and the likely
gene disrupting testing variants on the
principal component analysis
through the known genes represented in
the blue region and the testing genes in
red
austin genes also have high expression
levels and similar expression profiling
as seen on the heat map however six
genes were identified as potential
autumn candidate risk genes labeled in
blue on the heat map and these were arh
gap 21 slit 1 atp 61d app bp2 snap 91
and sped 5.
next i visualize expression t
distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding and ridge plots
it was found that chd 7 a high
confidence gene and slit 1 1 k18 gene
identified in the study shared similar
expression profiling
however sdf4 and not associate gene had
little to no expression
all 16k genes had high expression in
greater than 10 cell types with their
age gap 21 slit 1 and atp 61d
consistently 10 folds higher expression
than compared to the average gene
a similar trend was seen on the tissue
plots which showed that the k genes were
widely expressed in multiple cell types
represented in the red regions circled
my third method was to provide
additional support for each canada gene
beyond gene expression through
identifying protein protein interactions
transcription factors and protein kinase
associations and past literature
the canadian genes were correlated with
past autumn associated protein
interactions especially the map k1 and
map k14 protein kindnesses which have
been linked to synaptic dysregulation
and autism in the past
there were five additional autumn
associations circled in red
table three also shows how the six genes
were mapped back to the three major
biological processes that were
implicated in autism
neurotransmitter transport synapse
functioning and awesome dysregulated
receptors see in figure two
my research provided a new alternative
approach to identify alzheimer's genes
and identified six potential autism
genes that could be incorporated into
genetic testing
my research also supports a midbrain as
an autumn risk gene hospital and the
high expression of austin genes during
the early developmental stages
with increased discovery of alzheimer's
genes more individuals with autism can
be diagnosed earlier and with greater
accuracy
my future research involves using
molecular rnac conversion probes to
analyze mutation inheritance and
genome-wide association significance for
mutation problems and autism cohorts
all the images in this presentation were
created by the student presenter
and these are my references thank you